(The Library of Congress event
Stories From a Fallen World:  A
Tribute to Denis Johnson will
begin in approximately three
minutes.
Please continue to stand by.)
(The
Poetry & Literature Center and
The John W.
Kluge Center presents Stories
From a Fallen World
:  A Tribute to Denis Johnson
2017 Library of Congress prize
for
American 56 winner
5656 winner.
)
56 fiction
American fiction winner..)
Library of Congress event
Stories From a Fallen World:  A
Tribute to Denis Johnson will
begin momentarily.  Thank you
for your patience.  Please
continue to stand by.)
(You are standing by for
Stories From a Fallen World:  A
Tribute to Denis
Johnson, presented by the Poetry
&
Literature Center and the John
W. Kluge Center.)
»:  Ladies and gentlemen, a
video
message from Carla Hayden.
>> Haydengoo.
»:  Thank you for joining us for
the event A Tribute to Denis
Johnson.  I'm sorry I can't be
there with you but I know it
will be a memorable conversation
with these extraordinary
authors.
(Standing by while the video
plays.)
» CARLA HAYDEN:  Some of the
biggest names in every genre.
In history I'm announce --
thrilled to announce that former
Secretary of State Madeline
Albright will join us.
John Meacham and others.
Best selling author Amy Tan will
discuss her new memoir.
Dave Egger and Isabelle Allende
will
be with us and Juneau Diaz will
join us.
Our poet lar yet, and ambassador
Jacqueline wood son will be
there too.  This is just a hint
of the things to come.  More
names will be announced soon.
I hope to see you there.
»:  Please welcome the director
of
national and international
outreach, Dr.
Jane McAuliffe.
(Applause.
)
»:  Good evening.  As you
just heard I'm the director of
national and international
outreach here at the Library.
On behalf of all my  colleagues,
it is
a pleasure to welcome you to
Stories From a Fallen World.
The Locke prize for American
fiction tribute to Denis
Johnson.
Tonight is the third in what has
become the annual celebration of
the prize for and its winners.
We all find pleasure in today's
hectic world to pause and take
an evening to recognize the
power of literature to change
our perceptions.
Along with our poet lar yet, the
prize for American fiction
stands as the
Library's highest honor to an
American writer.
It seeks to come mend strong,
unique, enduring voices who have
told us something new about the
American experience.
Denis Johnson certainly deserves
the
honor, as last year's prize
winner Marilyn Robinson has said
about him:  I
have known a writer who was so
identical with his work, whose
thoughts and
passions and nrks were so
entirely of one substance with
the world he remade as fiction.
The great energy of his
imagination was a fusion of
honesty and seriousness, pain
and laughter.  His life was a
thing of the moment and
urgency, pure and undistracted.
Denis left us too soon.  But we
have an amazing group of his
writing peers, literary and
journalistic here with us
tonight to help celebrate his
life and work.  It should be a
fascinating discussion
that reflects in strikingly
different
ways the gritty themes that
course through his  stories.
Before we get started I would
like to
recognize Cindy Johnson, his
widow and his  daughter, Lara
Burke.  We are glad you so join
us this evening.
I would also like to recognize
Avida,
the deputy publisher of Random
House, the proud publisher of
Denis' work.
Now, please let me welcome my
colleague, John  Haskell to the
stage to tell you a bit about
one of our hosts
this evening, the J1 Kluge
center here at the Library.
Thank you.
)
»:  Thank you, Jane and thank
you all for  coming.
The Kluge center is proud to be
cosponsor of this event.  It is
a continuation of a
collaboration we have had with
the Poetry & Literature Center
to celebrate the winners and the
prize for American fiction.  The
tribute to this particular
literary giant fits perfectly
into the Kluge center emission
which is to be a bridge between
scholars and writers on
the one hand and policymakers
and the interested public on the
other.
That is to foster a
continuing conversation of the
challenges facing democracies in
the 21st century.
Before we get to the program
I want to give a quick shout-out
to the national endowment for
the humanities
who has gotten the word out to a
lot of you about this event and
also to thank them for the work
they do in collaboration with
the Library.
Right now we have a brief video
featuring Denis Johnson.
»:  DenisEnglish words are like
prisms, empty, nothing inside.
Until they make rainbows.  So
says a character in already dead
a novel by the late great
American writer, Denis Johnson.
Johnson's stories as ledges of
his fans know are also prisms.
They are hard, mercy less,
Flinty and yet they too make
rainbows.
He has been called a writer's,
writer's writer.  They hold a
simple truth.  Those who bring
language to life recognize
Johnson's  gifts instantly.
His work has been called
profound and transsent dent.
Jonathan Franz finds his words
miracles of tone.
Philip Roth calls him
terrifying,
emissary for tortured broken
souls.
Marilyn Robinson marvels at his
energies, so inextricably we
haded to his words.  All agree
Denis Johnson has managed to
give us minimalist yet
distinctly
ecstatic and hallucinatory
rainbow  prose.
He is an American original, born
in Germany and raised in manila
La.
As a teenager moving back to
Washington, D.C. he came to know
the country and the characters
he would capture so vividly in
fiction.  He graduated from the
University of
Iowa and eferred MFA from the
Iowa writer's workshop where he
returned as a teacher.  He
taught at Texas State University
and University of Texas, Austin.
In the course of his fevered
career
he published novels, short
stories, journalism and poetry.
Among the best known work are
those
about flotsam and jetsom, tree
of smoke,
nobody move, already dead,
Jesus' son,
resuscitation of a hanged man.
Angels.  He received numerous
awards for these including a
National Book Award, a
Lannan fellowship in fiction,
writing award and 2008 he was
named a finalist for the
Pulitzer prize.  Throughout his
chronicles in America
that has gone unobserved,
unrecorded,
here are our drug addicts, war
veterans, disaffected, used up
and left behind.
The most affecting and
rewarding
aspect of Denis Johnson' fiction
is that in work after work he
proved that beauty
often lurks in unexpected
places, that strength can be
found in failure, that the human
spirit is a fragile but
resilient vessel.  His is a very
American story.
He once described his works as
pressure cookers of language,
his
characters as those who inhabit
life's perilous edge.
He found he himself was too vol
ner ability rable to human
frailties.
When Carla Hayden offered Denis
Johnson the price for American
fiction
in March of 2017 he wrote in an
email message:  My head is
spinning from such great news.
Two months later, tragically, he
was dead.
The Library is very proud to
honor posthumously this
extraordinary human beeping and
writer whose contributions
to the American canon are
invaluable.
As it was noted when the prize
was announced in 2017, Denis
Johnson was a writer for our
time, in proceeds that
feels graced with grit he spun
tale
after tale about demons, the
salvation we seek.
We emerge from his imaged world
with profound empathy, a
different perspective, a little
changed.
We are very proud to count Denis
Johnson among the distinguished
winners of the Library of
Congress Prize for American
fiction.
(Video ended.)
(Applause.
)
»:  Good evening, ladies and
gentlemen.  My name is Marie
Arana.  I have the privilege of
serving as the literary advisor
to the Library of
Congress and to the Librarian of
Congress Dr. Carla Hayden.  One
of my most rewarding
responsibilities is decking the
jury that governs this
distinguished award, the Library
of Congress Prize for American
fiction.
In that capacity, I get to work
with wonderful scholars like the
ones you've
just heard, Jane  McAuliffe and
John has kel as well as the
Poetry & Literature
Center, rob Casper whom you'll
meet at the end of the program.
Every year critics, Nobel
laureates,
man booker award winners, former
winners of this prize put
forward three American
authors they think most
deserving, the Librarian
Congress makes the will final
selection.
The purpose of that award is
spelled out on the back of your
programs.
It is to commend strong, unique,
enduring voices that throughout
long consistently accomplished
careers have
told us something new about the
American experience.
Past awardees have been her man
Wouk,
is bell Allende, Don Delillo,
John
Grisham, Marilyn Robinson, and
Toni Morrison.
The choice of our 1010th prize
winner, Denis Johnson, made by
Dr. Hayden in March of last year
and then confirmed in a prize
ceremony in
September, was especially
thrilling for
me as I have been a dedicated
fan of
Denis' work since I stumbled on
to resuscitation of a hanged man
back in the early '90s when I
was a little younger than I am
now.
I found myself  bowled over by
his
language, its emotional force,
its precision.
As one reviewer wrote, "his
novels,
like poems, seem to be written
line to line."
But the full power of his
stories transcends even his
proceeds mastery.
Denis' stories land like a
switch punch, somewhere between
gut and heart.  The last time I
spoke to Denis it was on the
phone.
Trying to persuade him to be
here tonight.  He had been so
delighted by Dr. Hayden's call
and the news that he was the
chosen honoree.  I exchanged
emails with him just after that
call.
But he was also an immensely
private man.  He didn't like
public expressions of
admiration.  Indeed he had been
conveniently away
in some war zone reporting a
story when the National Book
Award was conferred on him ten
years before for his
devastatingly powerful work
"Tree of Smoke".
I tried Valiantly to argue my
case that he should join us
here.  That he didn't need to do
much.  Just come, sit out there
in the audience with all of you
and be lauded and celebrated and
given his due for being one of
the great American literary
figures of our time.
He was polite.  He was
friendly.
He let me talk and talk.
(Chuckles.
)
»:  That phone call which
lasts a good long while and I
felt every passing minute that
my  powers of persuasion were
failing me.
It ended with:  Hmm, I don't
think so.
(Laughter.)
» MARIE ARANA:  He just
couldn't bring himself to do it.
That was on May 18th, 2017.
Six days later, he was gone.
Now we are here, gathering to
honor
him in his absence.
Thinking about how to best
celebrate
denyness, we decided what might
prees
him most given his gym let eyed
view of public expressions of
admiration might be to turn our
lights in the other direction.
We decided to pay tribute to him
by honoring others in his name,
choosing three exemplary
American writers whose works
reflect in one way or another
the
themes that are so present in
Denis' work.  They would be
excellent writers at the top of
their form, very different
practitioners of the craft,
three greats
who like Denis tell stories,
fiction or
nonfiction.  Excuse me.
Stories of the fallen world.
The human cost of addiction, for
instance.
The terrible fog of war.
The essential alienation and
disconnectedness that defines
modern day America.  If we do
this right, tonight you will see
a little bit of Denis and his
obsessions in all three of these
brilliant words Smiths.
I would like to tell you
something
about each right up front, right
here before we sit down in
reverse order of their
appearance.  When I actually
bring them on, the last shall be
the first.
Let me start in that spirit with
someone who will actually follow
the writers.
She is Elizabeth Cuthrell, an
accomplished film producer who
produced
Jesus' son, that stark, serge,
offer
51ly, quirkily funny collection
of stories for which Denis is
probably best
known, Elizabeth is founder of
Evenstar
films, she turned out many
movies as well as acclaimed
theater productions on both
coasts.  She produced a stunning
series of public service
announcements called stop the
hate.  Urging racial tolerance
for which she won the courage
award.
We are especially thankful and
very grateful to Elizabeth for
coming to
share with us Herlong time
friendship with Denis Johnson.
Sam Quinones is the author of
dream
land, a true master piece of
investigative journalism about
the IDEA
crisis that has ravaged small
town America and the heart land.
His book is powerful, absorbing,
urgent, a monumental achievement
that drills down on the harsh
realities that Denis described
so memorablely in fiction.
The winner of the national book
critic award, finalist for the
L.A. times book prize and named
one of the
best books of 2015, it is a book
every American should read.
A book that tracks a spiraling
drug trade, voracious,
unfettered pharmaceutical
industry, and hundreds of
thousands of lives strewn along
the  way.
We are very lucky to have Sam
with us tonight.
Elliot Ackerman, a United States
marine, served five tours of
duty in Iraq and Afghanistan and
is the recipient of the silver
star, Bronze Star for valor and
Purple Heart.  His essays and
short  stories have appeared in
the New Yorker, the Atlantic,
new Republic, among many others.
His first book "Green on Blue"
is a
har owing, brutal utterly
absorbing
novel about an Afghan orphan
trapped in
the savage fog of wall.  His
second novel "Dark at the
Crossing" published last year is
about a
young Arab American caught in
the Syrian con Florida gracious.
A finalist for the National Book
Award and named one of the best
books of 2017.
He will publish a new fall this
fall
about Eden, a veteran home from
the world,.
Great to have you here.
Our first guest tonight,
Jonathan Franzen is renowned for
plumbing the depths of the
modern American psyche,
past master of the essential
loneliness that permeates
contemporary life and the wild
careening twists of fate that
can throw it all out of whack
and send it spinning.
Jon's talent for forming
striking
narratives out of ordinary life
is a bun
daptly evident in his work, in
his
richly imaged novel, "Purity",
called
his most fleet footed intimate
novel yet.
If some authors are masters of
suspense, others post modern
verb
balance Acrobats, publishers
weekly
wrote and still other character
point
Lisas, few Excel in all three
arenas.  Jon is the author of
four other novels, among them
freedom and "Corrections" for
which he won a nationality book
award and other prize
Z, nine other works of fiction
and nonfiction.
Ladies and gentlemen, please
welcome Jonathan Franzen.
(Applause.
)
»:  I would like.
» MARIE ARANA:  I would like
to start with a quote, Jon.  Can
I be heard?  Yes?
This is from Sam townhouse of
the New York  Times.
He said Franz cracks open the
shell of post modernism, tweaks
out the circuitry and inserts in
its place the warm beating heart
of an authentic humanism.
» JONATHAN FRANZEN:  That was
nice of Sam.
(Laughter.)
» MARIE ARANA:  He writes
with equal fluency on equity
finance, railroad engineering,
currency manipulation in
Eastern Europe, neuro chemistry
of deprigs, but the data flows
through the
arteries of narrative, attending
to the
quite drama of life and fraught
transactions with the public
world.
That is a pretty big, tall
order.
Jon, you write about
dysfunctional
families, small American worlds
that are exploded, really by
large events.  I think I can
summarize your work that way.
And the hum drum of quiet lives
suddenly ripped to sleds by
economic
events or miscommunication or
happenstance.  What brings you
to those subjects?
(Laughter.)
» JONATHAN FRANZEN:  Sheer
desperation.  That's kind of
what you face every morning in
the office.
First of all, thank you all for
coming.
I never do these things.
There's only one writer I would
have done this for and that is
Denis Johnson
because he has a unique place,
actually, in the world of
American literature.
He is the one writer to every
writer I
know can quote multiple lines
from verbatim.  They are often
very funny lines which is
something I hope we don't lose
sight of.  Denis was one of the
funniest writers we had.
Laugh out loud funny precisely
because he was so close to the
will edge.
So it is an honor to be here and
I'm so glad Cindy can be here
too.
So, oh, yeah, my work.  Hmm.
Whew.  It is auto biographical.
It is just to get at the stuff
that I'm interested in.  I am
very bad at writing about
myself.  I think there are two
kinds of writers, one who can
pretty much only write about
himself and her seven and the
other kind.  And I'm the other
kind.
Than and I like a good story.
And typically good stories are
about characters who want stuff
and also if they are anxious,
then the story might be funny.
And if I'm not laughing, then I
am just setting those pages
aside and trying something
else.
And I guess, yes, and I always
paid attention to the news.
I had a dad who was very attuned
to --
he had no education really
except as a
civil engineer, but he thought
about stuff.
And dinner table conversation
when I was growing up would be
about what was happening in the
world.  So that just seemed
natural.  Also it is nice if you
have a character who wants
something, to put
that character in a recognizable
world.
It just seems like, you know,
it's what I do.  That was a sort
of inarticulate response, but
the articulate response would
eat up the rest of our time
(Laughter.)
» MARIE ARANA:  Well, you are
pretty
articulate on the page, Jon.
» JONATHAN FRANZEN:  Where it
counts!
(Laughter.)
» MARIE ARANA:  Where it counts.
But you really do, I think, more
than many American writers who
are dealing
perhaps with, you know, plot
driven or
shall we say small domestic
troubles,
that there is a sense when you
read Jonathan Franzen that you
are reading
something about this anxious
age,
something about a kind of loss
of
connectivity that we seem to
have come to.  At least that's
what the critics say.
What do you say from your
perch?  About what you are
trying to do?
» JONATHAN FRANZEN:
Honestly, I am trying to be
funny and I find people who are
anxious very funny because I
feel that's the only way to
survive my own anxiety is to
step back and throw it into
somebody else and then laugh at
that person.
So, for instance, like in the
"Corrections", I spent -- I was
looking for a topic sentence,
just a little craft thing.  I
don't really have a character
until I can write a good topic
sentence about the character.
It all goes back to what we were
taught in seventh grade about
topic sentences.  It turns out
to be really true.  It can take
up to five years to come up with
a topic sentence for a character
for me.
(Chuckles.)
» JONATHAN FRANZEN:  But there
was a character in the
"Corrections", Gary, and it was
an elaborate topic sentence but
it had to do with, there was all
this attention in the '90s on
clinical depression.
Which Prozac was the miracle
cure for.
And he was basically trying to
demonstrate that he was not --
he was trying to do something in
order to demonstrate to his wife
that he was not clinically
depressed.  That was very much
of the time.  People were having
conversations -- instead of
saying I wish you would take the
trash out or clean up after
dinner more they would say you
have a problem.  You are
clinically depressed and the
other person would say no, I'm
not clinically depressed.
You're clinically depressed.
(Laughter.)
» JONATHAN FRANZEN:  So it
was hill air just, but those
were real fights.  I had been in
one myself.
(Laughter.)
» JONATHAN FRANZEN:  It was like
... and yeah.
So it is like okay, well I've
kind of got a handle on this
guy.  And yes, it does draw in
what is
happening in the world because
why not?  It's fun.
» MARIE ARANA:  Right, right.
» JONATHAN FRANZEN:  I'm an
entertainer, looking for what's
fun.
» MARIE ARANA:  Let me ask you
now, talking about real life.
Because one of the things that I
think would be really
interesting to explore,
particularly with your work, is
the way
that fiction in some ways gets
across a
reality better than sometimes
nonfiction can.
What does fiction in your mind,
how does it do that for a
society?  How does it feed us?
How does it nurture us in that
sense?
» JONATHAN FRANZEN:  I
actually think
the people who read Denis
Johnson level fiction are the
lucky ones.  And I don't mean
economically the lucky  ones.
I mean just lucky that something
is going right if you can
sustain attention in a novel.
If you are really miserable you
can't do that.
In the prison population there
are the readers and those are
the lucky ones.
In any population, it is
actually --
so if you can enjoy a book, you
should pause for a moment of
gratitude that you are able to
do that.  A lot of people can't.
If you can enjoy a complicated
dark book that laughs at things
that other people might find
terrible, you are  really,
really lucky.  That is almost a
definition of what we
call literature, is that kind of
cosmic distance on stuff.  If
you are down in the trenches you
can't do that.
Yeah, so I think I talk a lot
about
the metamorphose sis, France
Kafka's novel about waking up to
find you're an insect.
I could have done a midstream
memoir talking about how crappy
it was to live at home with his
parents and not even
have a good bedroom even though
he's the son.  And this is a
grown man, working a job for
years.  There he is at home with
the parents.
And he could have probably
gotten across some of why he
found that a drag.
» MARIE ARANA:  Right.
» JONATHAN FRANZEN:  But to get
at really the degree to which he
experienced that as unbelievably
terrible, he made you a story.
He invented something.
And also in the process good
thing for fiction, he protected
his family.
(Laughter.)
» JONATHAN FRANZEN:  Everyone
knew
that the Kafkas did not have a
large bug for a son.  And the
parents were oh, it's not us!
(Laughter.)
» JONATHAN FRANZEN:  How could
that be us?
(Laughter.)
» JONATHAN FRANZEN:  Franz is
a little weird but he is not an
insect.
I think that broadly speaking
that's a metaphor for what
fiction does.
It enables you to go exaggerate
in
these wild ways that mirror
representation of reality can't,
states
of mind, emotional states and
lots of
other kinds of states that mere
factual representation simply
cannot.
» MARIE ARANA:  Of course,
that
brings me, you are talking about
the way that fiction works, that
humor in
fiction and which Denis used so
superbly
in the middle of the darkest
sort of funkiest moments.
You would find it screamingly
funny.
» JONATHAN FRANZEN:  His word
choice in a fatal accident, the
first story?
Jesus' son, I think when the car
crash happens the woman says:
No.  The woman said viciously.
That word viciously, which is
like
ahead-on crash is about to
occur.
Yeah, that tells me he resolved
something.  And could see it
from the kind of
perspective in which things on
the one hand he's sort of
touching close to God.
On the other hand he's touching
-- it's all hilarious.
If you get the nuke story
collection if for no other
reason there's a two and a half
page scene of the numerator
having a knee examination in
surgical theater while tripping
on  LSD.
If there's any doubt he was a
comic writer ...
» MARIE ARANA:  Right.
In fact, you made a wonderful
citation at his prize ceremony.
And I want to read at least part
of
it:  You said his sentences at
best are miracles of
transparency and tone which
you've already heard, perfect in
the way they inhabit the page
but devoid of
vanity, always vivid in their
reference to the actual but
always conveying something
larger.
The creator's own self knowledge
and compassion and sense of
cosmic  comedy.  The God I want
to believe in has a
voice like Johnson's.
» JONATHAN FRANZEN:  Right.
(Laughter.)
» JONATHAN FRANZEN:  Oh, I don't
know.  Stress on want to, as in
wish I could.  But yeah, if
there were a God who
spoke with that kind of ...
I'm not going to try to
explicate that.
» MARIE ARANA:  Okay.  I think
what it meant --
» JONATHAN FRANZEN:  Thank you!
(Laughter.
)
» MARIE ARANA:  IfIf I may?
» JONATHAN FRANZEN:  You
absolutely may.
» MARIE ARANA:  That he
really had a
voice, I mean a very strong
voice.
If we could pinpoint that
talent, it
would be that voice that he had
that was absolutely unique and
original, as yours is, I would
say.
» JONATHAN FRANZEN:  Thank
you.
» MARIE ARANA:  That sense that
you
are in the hands of a really
superb
numerator and narrator and you
can't quite let go.  It's
mesmerizing, that voice.
» JONATHAN FRANZEN:  Thank
you.
» MARIE ARANA:  Is that what
you meant?
» JONATHAN FRANZEN:  No, I
was not talking about myself; I
was talking about Denis.
But ... yeah.
I thought actually Marilyn put
it nicely.
There is a sense of a kind of
unitary,
what he -- the writing and the
person were almost
indistinguishable.
It strikes me, and I think our
other
two guests who will soon join me
can speak to this.  He is
somebody who might very well not
have survived.
He was a kind of messed up kid.
And had intimate knowledge with
these, you know, pretty violent
and definitely addictive
situations.
And there is a sense of at the
core, I
think, of all of his -- I was
rereading the nuke stories on
the way down here.
The whole book kind of feels
like a meditation -- not a
meditation.  It is a
representation of the
amazingness of still being
alive.
So that there is something about
everything he wrote that is
aware of the proximity of death.
That goes to, in that respect I
think
there's a subterranean
connection with
flan ry O'Connor, in her
greatest of all
her great stories, a good man is
hard to
find, it would have been a good
man if somebody had been there
to shoot her every day of her
life, about the grandmother in
that story.  If you don't know
the story, go read it.
Which is basically -- this was a
trivial woman who with a gun
pointed at her suddenly found
something.
And somehow throughout his
career he managed to write the
stuff that felt right on that
bubble of there's a gun pointed
at me.  Death is all around me.
I've seen people die.  I'm aware
that I'm going to die.
And there is a line in the new
book,
you know, I like my wife.  She
is, you know, clever and rather
attractive.
She could die any minute.  And
then he just says that.  New
paragraph, we're on to the rest
of the story.  But that seemed
to me kind of the essence of the
work.  That's why what makes it
so exciting
is that  there's always death
right there.
» MARIE ARANA:  Right there,
yes.  Well, with death right
there, let's bring on Elliot
Ackerman.
(Applause.
)
» MARIE ARANA:  Here is a
quote.  He.
» ELLIOT ACKERMAN:  That might
be my favorite introduction.
(Laughter.)
» MARIE ARANA:  Here is a
quote to
accompany  you, to have you
accompany us as I did for John.
This is from Ben fountain, who
wrote a
wonderful book called Billy
Lynn's long half time walk, if
you know it.  He wrote about
Elliot:  "Dark at the Crossing"
is every bit as taught and har
owing as the place it depicts, a
region
where 15 years of relentless war
play
out in refugee camps and
shopping mall.
He has written a mercyless novel
of broken lives, broken places
and good intentions gone awry.
Someone once said of you if I
remember correctly that they
don't award medals of valor for
writing, but maybe
they should to you.
There is a sense, Elliot, in
your books, both of them, that
you've merged
from the Calderon of hell to
tell this  story.
This is going to make Jon's
blood pressure rise because I
read somewhere that he hates
this question, but I'm going to
ask this question.  How auto
biographical are these stories?
In the sense that you have lived
through any -- of course you
lived
through the hell of war, but to
what extent are these from life?
» ELLIOT ACKERMAN:  Well, you
know,
my first book is the story of an
Afghan who is murdered by an
American.
All pulled from the perspective
of the Afghan.  So that's not
me.
And my second novel takes place
in
southern Turkey around the sir
Indian Civil War and those
characters are not me.  However,
they are deeply informed by my
experience.  I don't think I
could extricate my experiences
from the book.
» MARIE ARANA:  Right.
But there is a sense, especially
in
"Green on Blue", that you are
not sure what side is which.
It remind he me of revolutions
in which the sides keep changing
all the
time because people see the
battles going this way, the
battles going that way and they
are going to run to whatever
side is winning.
There is that sense of divided
or confused  loyalties and the
fog of it all, in a sense.  That
is clearly something that you've
seen.
» ELLIOT ACKERMAN:  Well,
it's something that I have seen
and something I admire in other
people's writing and something I
admired in Denis Johnson'
writing, the ability to take
extremely complex political
events and make them feel
extremely personal.  It is
something that fiction does.
But then you get, talking about
like different sides of an issue
in a war.  For instance, there's
the -- what is the trope someone
just said the other day?  Maybe
it was on television, you don't
really know a person until you
have been divorced from them.
(Chuckles.)
» ELLIOT ACKERMAN:  That is
probably true.  I would appear
pend to that, you don't really
know a person until you've
fought on the opposite side of a
war from them.
And so I think there is sort  of
-- sometimes we'll see, why are
you so fascinated by the people
on the other sides f these
conflicts?
In some ways they are the people
you
know the best until, trot out
another
» MARIE ARANA:  Particularly in
Iraq and Afghanistan you are
fighting alongside people who
are of that land
and with whom you have to make
bonds.
I mean, one thing I think that
you
said so eloquently is that a
marine is trained to kill,
right?
But he also has to be trained to
love.  And why?
Because he has to throw himself
in the
line of fire for his buddy, for
his
compatriot, for the person he is
fighting with.
That really interests me, that
notion
of you are essentially falling
in love
with or loving a person
whose life is at risk and who
may day or will die.
» ELLIOT ACKERMAN:  I think it
gets to sort of the topic of our
panel here and what is very
unique in Johnson's work is that
he is so often at the edge.
I would say it's also almost
like an  extremely thin membrane
that is translucent when you are
standing right
up against issues, particularly
issues of conflict and war.  We
are fascinated by that subject.
The difference between love and
violence is so permeable.
So I mean, I found in my own
experience, I have found in my
own
experience in war, some of the
great ironies, people are doing
courageous things because they
love each other but the
courageous things they are doing
are incredibly violent.  You are
constantly flipping or
permeating that membrane.
» MARIE ARANA:  Speaking of
membranes, the "Dark at the
Crossing",
deals with an Iraqi who is born
in Iraq but an American citizen.
And we can't help but wonder as
we
read it and he wonders it
himself where his loyalties lie.
And what it means to be true to
one's self when you have two
identities at
work, two nationalities at work,
two loyalties.
And how did you get to that
subject?
How did that come to you?
» ELLIOT ACKERMAN:  This
character who is an Arab
American, basically
decides he wants to go cross
into Syria to fight for the free
Syrian Army.  A lot of the book
is about unpacking his
motivations.
It gets to what Jon was just
saying with the flan ry O'Connor
story about
the gun and in Stanley cube
Rick's book.
They say animal mother is a
great guy.
You just need someone to throw
hand grenades at him the rest of
his life.
He is in the same position, but
to be
honest with you, the thing that
was for most in my mind wasn't
anything that happened in the
war.
It was a scene in Anna Karenina
and the way it ends.
Spoiler alert, she throws
herself in
front of a train and commits
suicide.
(Laughter.)
» ELLIOT ACKERMAN:  Her lover
gets a bad wrap.
The world hear tough on
Veronsky.
He's disgraced, and the last we
see of him, you don't see him
but you are told
by another character that he was
last
seen on a train headed to the
caucuses
to rejoin his regiment.
He could be rejoining his
regiment because he thinks it's
a battlefield, the way he can
redeem himself and integrate
again into society.  Okay.
Or he could be going there, he
could
be on that train for the same
reasons as
how Anna ended herself, going to
war to kill herself.
You never get the whole story
from Tolstoy.
I was  fascinated, people can
engage in one act, go to war for
reasons they don't even know
themselves.
It could be a redemptive or
destructiontive act.   That's
something I was hoping to
examine.
» MARIE ARANA:  Well, you as
Denis
did in "Tree of Smoke", that
sense of
the complete sort of suspension
in a
kind of wild card situation.
» ELLIOT ACKERMAN:  Like in
angels, one of my favorite books
of his, you
have this sort of -- it is not
banal, but every day.  Opens on
a bus.  There's a guy meeting a
woman on the bus, she has a kid.
You end up in the middle of a
bank robbery.  The way he could
slip you from the banal into the
very, very violent and put you
in situations where you can't
imagine that you're in.
I think that was the wonderful
thing
he did in his work and I aspire
to do in my work.
Violence is so banal.
» MARIE ARANA:  Dealing with
violence, it seems to me it is
so
physical, it's so concrete and
it is all around you.
And yet you deal with these war
situations.
But you also said at one point,
Elliot, you quote actually
Faulkner in which you say the --
he said the only thing worth
writing about is the human heart
in conflict with itself.  That
being the conflict, not being
the
conflict that is around you
concretely and possibly
threatening your life.  It seems
what interests you more is the
internal conflict that is going
on even as that conflict is
happening.   » ELLIOT ACKERMAN:
I think it's a thing that
interests most people.  I mean,
characters are interesting.  You
know, once you start getting
into
-- you were talking before about
what does fiction do?  It takes
you into the internal lives of
these people.  That's where the
compelling sphoars arise and
where the emotion exists.  Why
write fiction?  I think if you
are able to make someone feel
something, they will remember
what they felt in a way they
might not remember what they
read in the paper that morning.
» MARIE ARANA:  Uh-huh.
One last question for you and
that is:  You're a warrior.
» ELLIOT ACKERMAN:  On my good
days.
(Laughter.)
» MARIE ARANA:  And you know,
warriors come home and things
happen.
And do we -- I'm trying to take
this
out to
a more social or political
question, if you will.
Why do we revere warriors?
We revere warriors from afar.
When they come home riddled with
problems, when they may be
addicted to
drugs or beating their wives or
as a female beating her husband
or not being good to the
children, why is it that we are
not so good at confronting those
issues that they bring home?
» ELLIOT ACKERMAN:  Well, I
think in some respects it's easy
at that point to look at them as
the other.  You know, I've often
I think probably most people who
have my background have had the
experience of someone saying to
them:  I could never imagine
what you went through.  I'm like
yeah, you can.  I'm sure you
can.
You can maybe pass by a car
accident
or you lost someone in your own
family.
At the same time saying I can
never imagine what you went
through, it always
is unsettling to me not only
because it shows -- because it
puts up some like lack of
empathy.  It's like if you can
never imagine what I went
through or someone went
through, what you are basically
saying
is I have been so inalterablely
changed by an experience or one
has been, that you can no longer
identify with them.  So if you
can't understand what I went
through, that means I am so
unalterablely changed, I can
never go back to being the
person I was before I left.
If I can't, in effect I can
never come home.
» MARIE ARANA:  Right.
» ELLIOT ACKERMAN:  That is
somewhere we just can't be.
So I think that maybe to answer
your
question, just a general lack of
empathy, lack of being able to
see ourselves collectively in
these wars.
» MARIE ARANA:  Right, right.
With that I want to bring on Sam
Quinones, who deals with issues
of ...
(Applause.
)
» MARIE ARANA:  -- and here
is what I want to read about
Sam.
This is written by Laura Miller
at slate.
Many nonfiction are padded
features, but dream land, the
three pronged story
of how heroin addiction became
epidemic
in small town mart, Sam had to
quit his job at the L.A. times
to write.
You, from the hollowing out of
the
middle class to the greedy
marketing of pharmaceutical of
opiates to the
residents of the obscure Mexican
state
of  Nairete these create a oitd
add
ficted, residents priced out of
pill
mills turn to a newly cheap
choice.
This illuminates a catastrophe
unfolding around us right now.
Sam, you covered the border,
the U.S.
Mexico relations, you have been
a Latin
American correspond dent for
many years.
At what point did the opioid
epidemic grab your attention?
» SAM QUINONES:  I grabbed
the story when I was at the L.A.
times about a small town in
Mexico where everybody comes to
the United
States to sell heroin like
pizza.  So there's a delivery
system where you
call a number and then the
operator takes your order and
then dispatches someone to meet
you.
It's basically domino's pizza of
heroin.
And I came upon it when I was
talking
to a guy with the DEA in
Columbus.  He said we have this
system here, these guys doing
this.  We have never seen this
before.  No guns.  They don't
use guns.
They are -- we can arrest them,
arrest them, they send more
people.
They reconstitute some kind of
mute ant very quickly.
And he said they are all from
the same town.
And that, I lived in Mexico for
ten years and I had written a
lot about --
you see this a lot across Mexico
where
towns, towns where people do one
job.
And there is one town in my
first book where everybody in
the town makes popsicles.
One of the great businesses for
arriving at the middle class in
Mexico is the popsicle business.
There's a business in Mexico,.
(Phrase.) and that's one town
that started that.
You go to the town and in the
front of
the town there's a two-story
concrete
popsicle statue saying thank you
to the popsicle for bringing
them to the middle class.
When he told me that, I knew
he was right.  He didn't know
which town.
He said it was Tepique.  I knew
that was not.
It's a capitol city, 300,000
people.  It couldn't be true.
It had to be a small town.  I
wrote to guys he arrested in
federal prison.
One after another, I wrote 20,
30 letters to these letters,
hey, you want to talk about your
pizza heroin system basically,
is what it is.
(Chuckles.)
» SAM QUINONES:  One guy got
back to me.  Yeah, we're not
from Tapique.
We're all from Jalisco.  We are
all heroin traffickers.  I
thought at the time it was
Columbus because that's where I
first encountered this.
And then he began to say oh, no,
no, no we're all over the
country.  I could not explain a
few things about that.
First of all, they sold black
tar heroin.  My understanding,
knowledge of black tar heroin
was fairly extensive at that
point.  It is really for many
years only on the western side
of the United States.
They were selling in Columbus
and West Virginia, Tennessee,
places like that.  He began to
tell all the cities where they
are located now.  They moved to
Charlotte and they moved
to Lexington and Cincinnati
Andean appear list, et cetera,
et cetera.  All these different
towns on the Eastern side of the
United States.  And could not
explain why it would be that
heroin traffickers would have
such big business, such a new
market.  I thought heroin was
this old thing that no one
messed with anymore.  Everyone
knew it was a disaster.  Why
would you actually mess around
with heroin?
Why would there be huge new
numbers of people buying this
drug and using this drug?
That's really what got me on
to the larger  story, which is
the pain I will pes and the
opioids as we know them today.
It was really an attempt to
understand why Mexican heroin
traffickers, particularly from
this one town where I went.
I interviewed eventually a dozen
or so, ten or 12 guys who were
traffickers, all in federal
prison from this town.
And it was a way -- but I
understood
them to be the Vanguard of this.
They were the spear really
finding the market that was then
going to explode, which has now
happened.
But they found this market.
They knew what was going to
happen
back in 1998, 1999, 2000, what
is happening today all across
the country basically.
» MARIE ARANA:  Could you
tell us a little bit about the
scale?  You testified in
Congress not long ago p and I
watched the whole hearing.  It
was absolutely fascinating.  I
recommend it.
Opioids kill people every day.
In a scale, I think you said in
the
hearing that more people are
killed by opiates than by car
accidents in this country.  Tell
us about the scale that we are
talking about, the scale.
» SAM QUINONES:  The scale is
quite stunning, I think.  Yes, I
mean it must have been -- one
of the great moments or the
fascinating
moments I describe in my book is
when two public health folks
from the state
of Ohio realize that there is
about to
be a historic shift.  Since in
modern America the automobile
already has been the leading
cause of accidental death.
There has never been a time --
of course, that's gotten better,
we've gotten  safer, better
cars, et cetera.  So that number
was coming down.
In 2007 public health people at
the
state ofio ofio -- owe state of
Ohio, they figured out that was
going to end.
In the state of Ohio, overdoses
mostly
to narcotic pain pills and to
some degree heroin at that point
was over taking and going to be
the number one cause of death.
That wasn't true in Ohio in
2007.
Then it was true nationally the
next year.
And it is a stunning thing.
I think it is also very much an
under
count because this story begins
and is
most intensely felt in states
with too many counties.
Too many counties like Kentucky
has
400 people, Ohio has -- West
Virginia has ... reason the
reason that is important.  I was
a crime  reporter, started my
career in the crack days.  And
crack was very public.
Everything about it was public.
You couldn't avoid it.  It was
on the streets, drive-by
shootings, the gainings were
wealthy, violent, armed.  The
homicide rate went  up.
It stroyed neighborhoods.  That
wasn't happening with this.
Crime rates were dropping as the
deaths were rising.  You have
this transformation of what you
normally think of as very quiet,
right?
The doctors were the source
of supply.
I mean, this really starts with
narcotic pain killers, not
heroin.  The traffickers come
later.
American patients demand to be
fixed, American doctors, and at
the same time you have parents
and families wanting to hide the
fact that their kids are
addicted.  Nobody wants to
recognize that the obituaries
are almost all fabrications.
The only place you are going to
find this, the place where we
are going to recognize this is
the coroner's office, the
bodies.  The problem is in these
small countries, in the states
with too many
countries, the countries --
counties, we
fund coroner's  offices,
erroneously based on county tax
base.
The coroner's offices are small,
under funded  frequently.  They
don't have enough doctors in
these areas.
And they are susceptible to
family influence.
So don't put that in the death
report because it is going to
look bad for my dad or my
brother or my child or what have
you.
And so what is happening today
is
really, I believe, an enormous
plague across the country,
certainly in large parts of the
country it's intensely felt.
That it is consuming families,
consuming neighborhoods,
consuming football teams.
Football is basically now a
gateway to heroin addiction in
America, in my opinion.
It is -- and it is also
destroying those areas.
In order for those areas to be
great again, they have to defeat
this problem.  Nobody is
actually going to go put a
factory in some area where half
the population can't pass a drug
test.
So the effect is massive and it
is --
but also for a long time it
really was unseen.
When my book came out, the
health policy advisor for
Hillary Clinton called me and
said Hillary is stunned.  This
is 2015.
She is in Iowa and in New
Hampshire and  stunned with the
ferocity with which parents are
m coulding to her and said we
need a solution.  They almost
didn't care about anything else.
I said yes because first of all
this is a topic that polls
poorly.  No one will admit on
the phone this is their most
important subject, right?  They
want to hide it.
But go out there, hug people, be
a mother to people.  They need
that.
You know, there are probably a
the
look of reasons she lost, but to
that she wrote a policy position
paper and that was ...
so my feeling is, this is a very
hidden, even today even though
the awareness is much greater
than it ever has been.
Even today it is, we are seeing
these icebergs and really down
below there is a massive,
massive issue that is
everywhere in the country.
» MARIE ARANA:  Veterans in pain
or people, recreational as well.
It seems to do the gamut, the
spectrum.
» SAM QUINONES:  Sure, but it is
all
connected to this idea that took
hold in
the mid 1990s that promoted by
pain specialists and by
pharmaceutical companies and
really eagerly accepted by
us, the American health
consumers, that narcotic pain
killers were known to be
virtually nonaddictive when used
to treat pain.
Therefore, the dangerous
corollary to that is it doesn't
matter how many of these pills
you get prescribed and many of
you I'm sure have gone for a
surgery,
the pain for which is going to
last two or three days.
You get 30 days worth of pills,
right?  Multiply that by
millions of Americans every year
for 20 years.
What you get is a massive supply
that has created therefore a
massive black market.
So you get kids going to parties
and saying, the quarterback in
the high school football team is
taking them, damn, I'll take
them.  Most of the addiction is
related in my opinion to supply.
I used to believe that our
addiction problems were due to
demand.  When you are in Mexico,
it's nice to believe that.
Mexicans want to believe that.
It helps them wash their hands
of our Bill nationality drug
problem.
Those grinning owes up there are
hooked on dope.  I was down
there and now I'm convinced it's
a supply issue and most drug
problems are.
People come to me, should we
legalize drugs now that you've
written this book?  I'm like,
what about this story makes you
believe we ought to legalize
drugs?  All of this is due to
legal drugs.
You unleash a vast, vast hyper,
very potent supply of legal
drugs on the
population and you will get
massive problems.  You know?  It
was a time of fantasy.  I often
point out these were years too
when we believed that many -- we
believed we were special and
therefore the old rules don't
apply to us.
So these were years when we
believed
it was very common for numerous
baseball players to hit more
than 60 home runs.  It happened
twice and has not happened
since.  They cracked down on
steroids, right?
We believe if you package all
these
nonperforming nasty home loans
into one
security and Standard & Poor's
stamps
that thing AAA, that's a
magnificent place to put your
money and we believe
that you massively prescribe
drugs derived from the Pope yum
poppy, that
that would not concrete -- opium
poppy,
that that would not create
massive drug addiction.
Unlike the subjects of Denis
Johnson, these are mainstream
people.
I had a drug addict tell me,
dude, it
was enough to watch make me stop
using.
When the cheerleaders and
quarterbacks started this.
It was an outside, rebel thing
but now it's very much
mainstream.
» MARIE ARANA:  I was going
to point out, in "The Largesse
of the Sea Maiden"
which was just published
posthumously by
Random House, wonderful book,
absolutely
marvelous book of short stories,
in many
ways a culmination of Denis'
talent.  He writes about a jail
bird's ability
to get high on the most
unexpected of substances.
At one point somebody brings in
a newspaper soaked in LSD and
everybody thinks that's a
newspaper, except that it is
satisfying.
This is a very different
thing that you are describing.
This is not -- it is --
» SAM QUINONES:  This is
almost entirely white people.
It starts in appear latch I
can't in
the Russ belt of course is -- in
the
rust belt where we are very
eager to ig norp and did ignore,
but by the time I
got on to the story it had
spread far, far beyond that.
Spread across America and spread
stunningly in my opinion, to
some of the very  nicest
suburbs.
Orange County is our heroin
Beltway in L.A. now.  Some of
the nicest suburbs where people
had done best in the economic
expansions of the say previous
20 or 30 years.  I always
thought it was stunning in those
areas people were getting
addicted
and dying from drugs used to
numb pain.
You look at lives and you go
what pain exactly do you feel?
It's a perfect  life.
In the history of the world, .
0001 percent have lived, of the
people ever to exist have lived
as well as you.
And you've got, you know, to use
these
drugs to -- but I mean, I think
that's
kind of the story that I
initially
believed that I was writing the
great
American American drug
trarvegging story.  I was a
crime writer.  That's all I want
to do.
I wanted to write about Mexico
and these gainings and
everything.
Yes, this is certainly that
story but there is a whole lot
more to it.  There's really --
what it comes down to is not
economics.
How do you say a rust belt town
in Charlotte North Carolina have
the same problem and make it
economic -- it is not an
economic story.
What it really has to do
with, I believe, my common
denominator, the best I can come
up with, is our own deep and pro
found isolation and destruction
of
community, which is why I chose
the pool, swimming pool in a
small town
called Portsmouth Ohio on the
Ohio river
for the metaphor really, the
central image of the book.  The
name of the pool was dream land
and the pool was a place where
everyone came together and grew
up.
It was a steel mill and shoe
factory
and bustling Main Street and
50,000 people.  The pool is
where they came together and
formed community.  Then the
steel mill leaves.  The shoe
factories leave.  The Main
Street just empties out, classic
fashion.  Half the town leaves.
Then everyone retreats
indoors.
Finally they can't sustain it
and dig up and destroy
"Dreamland" and replace
it with a strip mall and an
O'Reilly's
auto parts store as the anchor
tenant.
They become exposed not unlike,
I
believe, the Indians when the
Europeans brought smallpox.
They had no bulwark, community
bulwark to keep this at bay.
I think that is what we are
dealing with now in a deeper
sense.
Kind of with this opioid
epidemic that is coast to coast.
» MARIE ARANA:  This is what
struck
me about your hearing and I want
to bring Jon into this.
You said in the hearing that it
was at
that point where families from
all kinds
of classes classes would get
together and mix.
This was their community coming
together.
And a kind of real connectedness
there.
So much of what Jon writes about
is  disconnectedness, where you
are out of connection really
because your marriage
is falling apart, your economy
has gone bust and you don't have
a job in the mining town.
So my question is
and this is a Pollyanna
question, I
admit:  Fix the malaise, fix the
problem, fix the
disconnectedness.  Jon, what do
you think?
And you start to -- you actually
said in the hearing, Sam, you
said we've got to get back to
that.  We have to get back to
that connection and that
community.
What do you think, Jon?
» JONATHAN FRANZEN:  I would
respectfully disagree that I
write about dysfunctional
families.
I think the dysfunctional
families are likely to be found
where there is substance.
» SAM QUINONES:  Uh-huh.
» JONATHAN FRANZEN:  In fact, I
write about  highly functional
families.
The children are taken care of,
not dropped on their head.  No
drug addictions.
I'm an old leftist.  We have
been ground between the twin
grinding plates of consumerism
and kind
of -- which is an atomizing
force.  It makes the individual
consumer the most important
thing.  And in fact, I would
actually flip it around and say
the reason I'm writing about
families, I think of the family
as the one thing you can't -- no
matter how hard the two plates
grind, you can't actually
dissolve the family bond.  If
you are interested in
psychological
intensity in a novel which is
kind of cat nip for me, you are
naturally drawn to the family.
That's one of the few places you
can find it.  You won't find it
at the community level or
friendship level because of
this.  So yeah, I do think that
this -- then,
of course, corporate
pharmaceutical
forces and all of those things
you were mentioning and the
financial industry, the worst of
capitalism is piling on to
make these things worse.
» SAM QUINONES:  Heroin is
interesting to me because it
dawned on
me, piggybacking on what you
say, if you are a culture that
believes that stuff will buy you
happiness, the final stuff
that could potentially buy you
happiness
is this cruddy stuff that you
inject in your vein.
It is a final expression, that
philosophy of living.
» JONATHAN FRANZEN:  You are on
the Hedonic treadmill.  You are
--
» SAM QUINONES:  It's never
happiness.
» JONATHAN FRANZEN:  Of
course.  It makes you feel like
you've attained it a moment.
Until then you haven't attained
it anymore.  You have to get
back.  What I found interesting,
frankly, was that the same guys,
the Mexican guys I was writing
about, they never used their
dope.  They would use cocaine.
They would drink, but they never
used their dope.  But they were
also addicted.
They were addicted to, as poor
young
men, leaving home, being poor in
Mexico is not just about having
not very much money.
It's also being humiliated for
not having very much money.
They would come home with money.
That was their narcotic.  They
would accumulate one of the
things that they loved to
accumulate was Levis 501 jeans
because those were the
classic, rural gold standard for
rural
men's wear when I was there in
Mexico, Levis 501 jeans.
And all of the narcotics dealers
would trade them for the dope,
take the jeans home and give
them away like Santa Claus.
All these guys who they had
grown up
with, all the girls want to talk
to them.  All these men would
come and talk to them about
loans.  That's a good thing, you
don't get asked for loans unless
you have money to actually give
them.
There's this feeling
throughout the research that I
had that everybody was
kind of addicted to something,
but it was not -- they were
looking for happiness.
The truth is, happiness, this is
pleasure.  Happiness doesn't
come from that.  It's all that
consumer culture that you are
referring to that I think is a
very, very big part of our life
here.
» MARIE ARANA:  It's almost
like it actually is reminding me
of something that Denis wrote.
That sort of vulture feeling
certainly.
His journalism in Liberia and he
-- I can't remember if this was
for Esquire
magazine or what it was for but
he was
describing the tremendously
nightmareish
war in which the dogs are
looking very prosperous.  And
the people are starving.  And
the reason why the dogs are
looking so prosperous is, of
course, they are feeding on the
Corpses.  I don't know why, and
it's a very, very dark image.
(Laughter.)
» SAM QUINONES:  You can say
that again.
» MARIE ARANA:  But it suggests
to me, and Elliot maybe could
comment on
this, that it is almost a
metaphor that
in the consumer business.  It
also, you know, in the business
of
war, that there are Corpses all
about.  People are dying.
It's a crisis, just in the
newspaper
today the headline, nearly 1
million people, mains are not
working because they are too
sick from opioids.
Last year it was 70,000 people
dead.  The year before that it
was 64,000 people dead, more
than the Vietnam War.
There is this sense of the
industry
devouring almost in a sort of
war-like way the victims.
And there seems to be a failure
afoot of responsibility in the
sense that what could we have
done?  Where could we stop it?
What can we do now?
A little bit of a war theme, I
would think.  Elliot?
» ELLIOT ACKERMAN:  Yeah, sorry.
I think definitely what you -- I
mean,
you know, wars build their own
economies.  I'm sure you've seen
this in your reporting.  We have
an American conception of war as
war begins.  It is fought for a
cause.
It ends and somebody wins and
somebody losses.  The reason
we're in the 17th year, for
instance, of fighting in
Afghanistan is not because we
haven't found that
perfect bit of alchemy my to
defeat the Taliban or whoever we
decided the enemy is.  You get
into the cycle where the war
just feeds upon itself.  Why is
that?  One part can be the
internal dynamics
in Afghanistan or in Iraq and
all those reasons we feel are
very, very far away.
If we turned the light on
ourselves,
it's because every war you go
to, you go to war with a
construct.  Whether it's the
national mobilization that
existed in the second world war,
where the entire country got
behind the effort, to the draft
in the Vietnam War, to today
where we are fighting wars that
are resourced with an all
volunteer military and funded
through deficit spending.  Kind
of like your pain killers, you
don't feel a thing and it goes
on and on and on and on.
» JONATHAN FRANZEN:  Sam, is
it your impression, you say it's
about supply.  That seems to
imply that these are people who
if they hadn't happened to
have access to the opioids, they
would have had good success full
satisfying lives?
» SAM QUINONES:  Yeah.  It's
hard to say.  You're right.
(Overlapping speakers.)
» JONATHAN FRANZEN:  I mean, the
mention of Afghanistan puts me
in mind -- as I said, we were
talking back stage.
There is an overlap between
areas of -- certainly where the
opioid crisis first made itself
particularly visible and Trump
America.  That there is a kind
of despair and kind of let's
burn it all down quality.  That
is absolutely what happens if
you tear up a country with 17
years of war.
There is like why not keep
fighting?
» ELLIOT ACKERMAN:  But there is
also a sense in what you were
talking about
too, which is this fan tastia we
are living in.  We can have
opioid drugs and everything will
be fine.
Also the sense of oh, yeah, we
can
hollow out our institutions and
we'll be psychologically okay.
We'll resource our wars out to
other people and pay taxes and
it will be fine.  It was
probably a good thing that we
had a draft in the '60s and
everybody got to a point where
they said this makes no sense,
we are not doing dit anymore.
» JONATHAN FRANZEN:  Exactly.
100 percent.  I said this in
fact in talks that I have been
giving around the country about
this.
That it is like -- yeah, we just
have
this -- the whole theme really
is to me, I thought again it was
drug traffics.  It is not that.
It's isolation versus community.
You know, we used to treat pain
in a variety of ways.  One
person would get a variety of
approaches.  So it would be, you
have pain, chronic paper.
Well, cognitive behavioral
therapy, diet, swimming.   Pain?
Marital counseling!  You need
that.  Marriage is pain!
(Laughter.)
» SAM QUINONES:  Seriously,
that's why part of what went
into ...
but then the pills took up all
the, we began to believe in easy
answers to complicated problems.
We began to -- I told an
audience the other day, I can't
remember where it was now, that
one of the worst things we ever
did was go to war and then give
ourselves a tax cut.
It's like we didn't really, this
one infinitesimal part of our
population was going over there
to risk their lives to fight the
war and we were not supposed to
feel anything.
We want to be  narcotized and
immune.  What is very important
in all of this, we were not
asked to be accountable and with
pain either.  We were not asked
to say you know, when you have
chronic pains, very often
it has to do with your own
personal consumer  decisions.
You don't get enough exercise.
You eat poorly, smoke, drink, ar
variety of things.
Doctors found the patients
don't want to hear that.
So they just said doc, I want
you to fix me.  You're the car
mechanic, my body is a car.  Fix
me.
We got into this attitude that I
believe was also very kind of
just a
Narcotized attitude that we
don't want to have to deal with
our own  decisions or change our
way of living and part of
it was when we went to war and
took --
and we're happy to get a tax
cut.  One of the lowest points
in our culture frankly was right
there, really was a very sad
day, I thought.
» MARIE ARANA:  Before we move
on to the last segment of this
program I want
to thank these extraordinary
writers who
in one way or another speak to I
think
Denis John's work, his sort of
miles an
hour rack miles an hour ac
allows ability to take -- miles
an hour ac allows themes that we
have talked about here and merge
them into the spectacular
literature.  Thank you to
Jonathan Franzen, thank
you to Elliot Ackerman, thank
you to Sam Quinones.  Before we
move on to the next part of the
program, the very tail end.
Thank you so much for coming.
(Applause.
)
» MARIE ARANA:  Now to tell us
about the personal, more
personal side of
Denis Johnson I want to welcome
Elizabeth Cuthrell to come and
talk about her personal
recollections and her work in
film with Denis.  Elizabeth,
please.
)
» ELIZABETH CUTHRELL:  Good
evening, everybody.  Thank you
for being here.  I think I'm
going to usher in a different
tone.  I hope that's okay.
I first met Denis in 1997 when
my partners and I were writing
the screen play for geez sus'
son.  We were just starting out
in the film business.  It was
our first project.
I was a huge fan of Denis' work.
I had somehow convinced him in a
phone call to let us take a
whack at the script.
I promised him if he hated it we
wouldn't make the movie.  And he
knew I men it.  We sent him the
first draft.  He loved it.  He
asked to come to New York City
to meet us.  He ambled into the
meeting wearing a
vintage a low ha shirt, red
cowboy boots and Elvis Presley
glasses held together in the
middle by tape.
I was terrified and thrilled to
meet this genius whose book we
were adapting.  He seemed shy
and amused at the same
time, but what I remember most
was his generosity.
He marveled at our a daptation
and talked to us like we were
the geniuses and he was the kid
just starting out.
I asked him if he would be
willing to play a part in the
film.  He said only if I can
play Terrence Weber, the guy
with the knife in his eye
(Laughter.)
» ELIZABETH CUTHRELL:  He added
that way, if I hate the movie I
can use my performance as a
metaphor.
(Laughter.)
» ELIZABETH CUTHRELL:  A year
later we were on the film set
together.  Denis was abusive.
He kept saying this is exactly
what it looked like.  This is
exactly what it felt like.
(Effusive.
) Jack black and Billy crud up
are in the hospital, hammered on
just a cocktail of uppers and
downers when a guy named
Terrence Weber, played by Denis
Johnson, arrives.  Here is the
clip.
(Movie played
.)
»:  I have been working in
the emergency ward for about
three weeks, I guess.
I had taken the job because
Michelle was pregnant and I was
trying to be responsible.
I had nothing to do on the
overnight shift.
I went bloking for George gi,
the orderly.  He often killed
spills.
»:  What am I going to do
about these fucking shoes, man?
(Music.
)
»:  Whatever you stole, I
guess you ate it already, right?
»:
(Movie captioned.
(Applause.
)
» ELIZABETH CUTHRELL:  Thank
you.
Collaborating with Denis on his
stuff was like stepping into
another world.  Something in me
would always get rearranged,
opened, challenged.  We worked
on a bunch of projects together
over the years and were cooking
up new ideas right up until the
end.
Denis was fierce about
protecting his work.  If
somebody tried to change, cut or
wrongly interpret his writing he
would be crushed but also do
what he had to do to protect it.
At a production of one of his
plays in Chicago he arrived for
the final dress rehearsal and
was stunned to realize the
director decided to use this
kind of sound machine to weave a
creepy weird background sound
into the production.  Denis
hated it.
He spoke to the director and
producer, but they wouldn't
budge.
So as a last desperate measure,
that night after everyone had
left, he snuck back into the
theater
(Laughter.)
» ELIZABETH CUTHRELL:  --
stuck the sound machine under
his jacket, went out and pitched
it into the river.
(Laughter.)
» ELIZABETH CUTHRELL:  Needless
to say he was locked out of the
theater from then on.
In his writing, Denis could be
mercyless but as a friend he was
profoundly kind.
He saw into you but didn't judge
you.  When you made a bad choice
he would
help you find something heroic
about it.  He was awake and
aware and in my opinion hooked
up to some sacred line.  There
were no layers on him.
He felt everything, every
infirmity in detail and at the
speed of light and that can't be
easy.
Whenever I asked him how he was,
he would always say I'm getting
better and better every day.
And in one of our very last
email exchanges he wrote:  I
thought late life was supposed
to be  boring.
I'm finding it more like a trip
over Niagara Falls.
He sometimes sent me emails that
read like prayers.
Here is one:  Elizabeth, my
darling sister, the other night
I was up for a couple of hours
around 2:00 a.m.  I call it the
night watch.  Sometimes it's the
best part of the day.  I had an
insight that I wish I could have
held on to.  That everything is
renewed, replenished,
perpetually.
That's what we are, that
replenishing.  I'm not the one
being renewed.  I'm the renewing
itself.  I'm not the one being
healed.  I'm the process of
healing.  That's the true me.  I
felt it, this truth, vividly.  I
was living it for a little
while.
Now it's just a concept again,
but a sweet one.  And here I
pass it on to you.
Denis' openness and sensitivity
sometimes made it hard for him
to deal
with the rest of us, especially
the crazy business side of art.
He told me when he was in L.A.
trying to get work made after
"Tree of
Smoke" came out, they would
proudly introduce them to each
other as Dave and say this is
Dave.  He won the National Book
Award.
(Laughter.
) these kinds of experiences
encouraged
him to retreat back to Idaho or
Arizona and earn his reputation
as being reclusive.  But there
was something about the process
of making plays, screen plays
and tele-plays that brought out
a part
of Denis that was jazz and
collaborative and social and he
couldn't stay away from.  He
loved actors.  He would
sometimes go into ecstatic
states listening to them make
sense of his work.
Here is part of an email:
Elizabeth what a privilege to
sit in the room and watch these
geniuses at work.  Afterwards
they talk about their
dinner plans head for an hour's
subway ride.
Go on as if it's possible to go
on after an experience like
that.  I go back to the
apartment.  Ten minute walk, and
try not to dissolve into the
galaxies.
Lastly, I want to talk just for
a
moment about Denis' wife Cindy
Lee Johnson.  There is no
talking about Denis without
talking about Cindy.  She was
his beloved.
When he spoke about her and
their
kids, beautiful daughter Lana
who is here tonight it was like
he was channeling sunlight.
Cindy took care of everything
the world demanded of Denis so
he could make art.
She was his Buoy.
Once Cindy took over the
checkbook, the repo man stopped
coming for his car.  He would
say I don't know how she does
it, does she clip coupons, buy
everything at a fire sale?
She dazzled him.  Her love
transformed his life.  He would
say when Cindy goes somewhere
even for a short while, it is
like God has died.
This is my last story.  I
remember one afternoon when
Denis
was giving a talk at the new
school in New York City.  It was
a rare appearance, totally sold
out, standing room only.  It was
raining, he got there light.
Someone appeared and rushed him
through aside door and up on the
stage and he got separated from
Cindy.  Another writer was going
on a bit long
with accolades and I noticed
Denis  looking agitated.
When he finally got to the Mike,
he put his hand to the forehead
and the
first thing he said was, Cindy
Lee, hone, where are you?
And she raised her arm and
called back:  I'm here.
He smiled his incredible boyish
smile at the sound of your sign
and he said I can't see you.  Is
your seat okay?  Where are you?
Can you stand up?  She stood up
and said yes, I'm okay.  I'm
here.  And they smiled at each
other and flirted and he said:
All right, then.  And began to
read his story.
All right, then.
It is my great honor to
introduce my
precious fremed, Cindy Lee
Johnson
friend, Cindy Lee Johnson.
(Loud applause.
)
»:  Good evening.  Thank you,
Elizabeth.  Thank you to all the
panel members.  What a
wonderfully unusual tribute.  I
love it.
I also want to thank all the
ladies and gentlemen of the
Library of Congress
for bee as  ting the esteemed
prize for American fiction upon
my beloved husband.  He so
richly deserves it.
When I met Denis he was 39 years
old.  I immediately recognized
him as the best looking man in
the world
(Laughter.)
»:  I fell in love
straightaway.  Only later did I
realize he was the
best writer in the world, in my
humble opinion.
But he was also this brave
Pilgrim soul who traveled the
planet from
searching for pirates in the
Sulu sea to
being the last American in
Somalia when the U.N. withdrew.
Consider this from a letter he
wrote in 1991.
Dear astronaut selection
officer, I am a civilian who
would like to be
considered for the one-year
astronaut training program.
That's right!  He tried to go
into space
(Laughter.)
»:  He was like a modern day
Tom Sawyer.
Often he would embark with just
a fishing vest filled with
everything he imagined he might
need and a face that
he would encounter helpers,
teachers and guides along his
path.  And he always did.  His
life was a grand adventure.  He
loved this world.  He loved his
family.  And he loved his work.
I am so grateful to have his
work, his light shines through
in his writing.
And it is a gift to the world.
But oh, how I miss that man.
I will always love him.
And so to close, a slide show.
I believe it will bare out my
best looking man in the world
comment.
Also please keep an eye out for
that fishing vest.  Thank you.
(Applause.
)
(Playing van Morrison
"into the mystic
mystic".)
(Applause.
)
»:  Thanks so much, Cindy,
for helping us end this
celebration on such a personal
and powerful note.
I'm rob Casper head of the
Poetry & Literature Center and I
would like to call Cindy,
Elizabeth and all of the
participants back out on to the
stage.  Please, come on out,
Cindy and Elizabeth.
Please join me in thanking them
again
for an amazing, amazing night.
(Applause.)
»:  ROB CASPER:
Thanks to all of you for
coming.
If you want to leave with a few
more books in your hand, our
presenters will
be signing books next door in
the woodall pavilion.  Before
you go to get the books, please
fill out the survey you got when
you first walked in the door.
You can drop them in the back.
We hope to see you in a few
weeks time for the poet lar yet
spring event.
Until then, have a good night
and again, thank you for coming
out.
(The event concluded at 8:50
p.m. EDT.